في المسجد الاقصى المبارك هناك العشرات
ممن ادوا صلاه الفجر وتمح لهم بالدخول الى
اداء صلاه الفجر ومنع عدد كبير من الشباب
الذين توافدوا
الماضيه الى اعراض البلده القديمه
المبارك
فيعني هناك حاله توتر حتى هذه اللحظه في
ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك الاسرائيليه
نعم اسمح لي فقط للتعليق على هذه الصوره
يعني ارادوا اداء الصلاه يسمى صلاه
الاشراق
ومنعوا من اداء الصلاه
اعتداء على مصلين يصلون ارادوا ان يصلوا
صلاه
خارج المسجد الاقصى بشكل جماعي دخلت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وافسدت عليهم الصلاه منعتهم من اداء
الصلاه
يعني الصوره تحكي المشهد
ارادوا ان يصلوا بشكل جماعي فتم منعهم
وبعد ان شرعوا بالصلاه تم افساد الصلاه
عليهم واخراجهم من الصف وتنتشر الان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في باحه المسجد
الاقصى وتبعد
بشكل واضح
الفلسطينيين من باحات المسجد الاقصى وهو
في كل مكان الان في العالم العربي
والاسلامي هذه ساحات المساجد تكون ممتلئه
حتى طلوع